[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing lord voldemort and the
fear-inspiring
poget pockets are essentially the
manifestation of our deepest darkest
fears
they are immortal shape-shifting
non-beings that transform themselves
into whatever it is that we fear most
no one knows what a boggart looks like
by itself except for perhaps mad imodi
because generally they transform as soon
as you encounter them when boguts aren't
scaring people
they can usually be found rustling
around in confined spaces
or lurking around dark corners similar
to poltergeists which have an affinity
for mischief
and dementors which thrive on darkness
and depression rockets are paired with
fear
another frightening fact about pockets
is that when they transform into
something
they adopt the properties of that thing
i.e when a boggart transforms into a
dementor
it's able to do all the horrible things
the dementor can
the boggart's power however will be much
less potent than the original being
if you fear several things equally then
a bucket will manifest itself in the
form of each of your fears
cycling through them for maximum
emotional scarring
the best way to defend against a bogut
is ridiculous aka the bogat banishing
charm
which makes the boggart look well
ridiculous and hard to take seriously
many characters have voldemort as their
boggart and this is understandable given
he is one of the most fear inspiring
beings in the wizarding world
but what's interesting is the bucket for
voldemort himself is never revealed in
the books
so what is the dark lord the man who
instills fear in everyone else
fear himself when jk rowling was asked
this very question in an interview
she responded with the following
voldemort's fear is death
ignominious death i mean he regards
death itself
as ignominious he thinks that it's a
shameful human weakness
as you know his worst fear is death but
how would a boggart show that i'm not
too sure
i did think about that because i knew
you were going to ask me that
a corpse that was my conclusion that he
would see himself
dead but there must be more depth to
this answer
yes voldemort's obsession is to cheat
death but does that necessarily mean
that he would see his own corpse
or could this fear of his own death
manifest itself in a different form
rolling seems somewhat unsure of her
answer the following exchange between
dumbledore and voldemort in the order of
the phoenix brings light to voldemort's
inability to process the concept of
death
you do not seek to kill me dumbledore
called voldemort his scarlet eyes
narrowed
above such brutality are you we both
know that there are other ways of
destroying a man
tom dumbledore said calmly merely taking
your life would not satisfy me
i admit there is nothing worse than
death dumbledore
snarled voldemort you were quite wrong
except dumbledore
speaking as lightly as though they were
discussing the matter over drinks
indeed your failure to understand there
are things much worse than death
has always been your greatest weakness i
think that more than anything
voldemort is afraid of the unknown death
brings so many questions along with it
and it is voldemort's inability to
process or conceive what might happen to
him
that scares him just so much and this is
a perfectly normal response
because of this i don't agree that
voldemort's bogut would be his own
corpse already deceased
i think that his pocket would be him on
the brink of death with his demise
imminent
i say this because if he is already dead
then what he supposedly fears most would
have already happened
if he's in a state of dying but they're
slowly enveloping his life force
and i think that in this state he would
be most afraid he would lie there
helpless forced to consider what he
fears most
the unknown and that's it for this video
what do you guys think do you prefer
jk's original answer or my theory
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you